when Prince he said he was starting his
own school today we just started the
Prince EA life school everyone
collectively thought to themselves
no please no a youtubers start their own
school this is gonna be terrible but
there's only one way to find out
definitively so I did it for you so you
don't have to I joined up so as you know
school doesn't teach you everything you
need to know to succeed in your life in
your relationships and in your mindset
so I created my own school every Monday
to Friday I will send you personal
messages for me sent straight to your
phone
two weeks later hello I've gone to
Princy school and it's just as terrible
as we all thought I was on the
schoolyard and actually a bully pushed
me every which is why I have this wound
on my pinky right now it's kind of
messed up I wish princey would have some
stronger anti bullying procedures okay
before we get into princey school who is
this guy right you might be asking
yourself who's princey if you haven't
seen him he's the guy he's making all
those inspirational videos on YouTube so
I pakal's my mind even though we cherish
our eyes so many people live without
having a clear vision now a lot of
people have already criticized this guy
Dave from boyinaband
calling him out for his misinformation
know the person does not always go see
it looks like you're mixing up this
Wikipedia page with this one you have
nerd city calling him out for his odd
turned from a rap career into
inspirational coach I don't want to be
so cynical but the princi pivot to
motivational Facebook stuff because
that's what was getting views this is
this channel mostly princey the rapper
princey in a polo is this little piece
right here but I'm not gonna focus on
any of those criticisms even though I
think it's probably valid because I'm
here for one reason I'm here for the
learning so the question is Prince E's
career and whatever aside how's the
school because you might think that this
is maybe the perfect place for Prince e
because
he's been a huge critic of the school
system well the time has come no more
excuses I called school to the stand and
accuse him of killing creativity
individuality and being intellectually
abusive he criticizes it over and over
and over and over in some of his most
viral videos are pointing out all the
failures of a mass educational system
you want to get a kid to hate reading
give them this a school textbook so how
does princey solve these problems does
he solve them in what ways
princey seems to be well positioned to
try to do it better as so many people
have done before so how is Prince E's
life school well kind of terrible
because it's not a school at all it's
more like a text Club now one thing I
want to say in advance is Prince II used
clickfunnels which is a famous thing we
talked about clickfunnels users all the
time like Kevin you-know-who dan Locke
all these fake gurus I'll say Prince II
like his his advertising isn't to Shady
he doesn't promise you the world his
these prices aren't too expensive so I'm
gonna actually call him not a not a fake
guru in the traditional sense of how we
normally talk about fake gurus he's just
kind of offering a bad value for your
money because he really doesn't promise
much he just says I'm gonna send you a
text message every day and he kind of
does that but to call it a school is
just kind of silly because what he
actually does is sends you like
one-minute inspirational messages audio
messages and they remind me a lot of
something you know your mom might send
you when you're going to school like in
your lunch box you know like did you
ever guys ever do that you'd have your
little lunch box and your mom would send
you a little note in it that says like
be happy or smile more or you know be
kind that's basically what the prince
sees life school is and I never had to
pay for my mom's messages so I don't
know why I'm paying for this it doesn't
seem like it's worth $9 a month like
here's an example here's Prince II for a
minute talking about breath talking
about why you should breathe breath
is life no really breath is life
I mean without Brett no really not that
okay there is no life did you know that
people with breathing problems are more
likely to have depression it's true
see breath dictates your mindset maybe
they're depressed because they have
breathing problems not that their
breathing problems are making you know
like I'm depressed cuz my asthma sucks
I can barely breathe maybe they're
depressed because of that not because
they're not getting enough air when
you're depressed or sad you can notice
that your breath is as well when you
inhale through your no I don't want to
get too far into the IP of princey here
you might uh go after me for showing you
too much of the text club that's already
like a quarter of the text message she
sent me on day two or whatever but yeah
you get the idea it's like your mom
saying hey try to breathe more hun and
you're like thanks mom for something I
already knew you know this is just kind
of this is throughout his thing today's
was gratitude movie limitless with
Bradley Cooper
sapir and within minutes he's super
intelligent better at his job and
relationships or did you know that you
can have all of those characteristics
without taking a pill I can look like
Bradley Cooper let's see why let's see
how wonder it's like some Indonesian
skin therapy or something it's called
gratitude gratitude is the healthiest
human emotion studies show is it though
is it the healthiest human emotion helps
you live longer it makes you happy
grateful people earn more at their jobs
have better again what kind of
correlation is this it just so happens
that people who earn more are more
grateful incredible lot people who earn
more nor living longer are more grateful
ah no no Prince eats a day so say
science has it finally proven that
science is gone too far for the last
time I'm putting a stop to this right
now boys getting ha get not right now
Prince he's trying to tell me that rich
people are more grateful which just
sounds insane to me I don't believe it
I don't believe it hold on sucker bites
I don't believe it
so this is basically what what you get
for $9 a month is just like five
messages a week sent to your phone so
it's just out of school and it doesn't
even have the piano music he's so famous
for like prints see if you ever watch
his videos they're notorious for this
swelling inspirational music that
contributes to a large part of maybe why
you like his videos you know the old
saying shoot for the moon and if you
miss you land amongst the stars here you
just get his like words which is
annoying
I thought breath was live breath his
life friends I didn't even notice this
brick Rather's life waters live by the
communicative property we can know that
if breath is life life is water and then
Brad this water frenzy science see you
yourself or 70% water okay so you're
annoyed right because it's just some
dude spitting nonsense but watch this
watch as I play some nice keys behind
this all of a sudden is gonna get a
little bit better okay so they're not
being there
[Music]
and your mood is bad yeah so verdict
it's garbage I mean I don't know what to
tell you guys don't get it I know we all
knew this but I just wanted to be you
know why not kill a little time join
Prince E's club see if it's really as
bad as I thought and yes it is it's it's
not really what you'd expect from a guy
who spent so so much time of his his
legacy criticizing the school system you
would expect if that guy was then to
create a school he would do a little bit
more than this he has not so far hey
guys future Steven here I just wanted to
say something real quick because I felt
like in the Edit I was coming off a bit
harsh I mean there are people I think
that maybe would enjoy this if you can't
get enough of princey if you can't get
enough obvious common wisdom being
spoken to you maybe this is for you I'm
just saying that's just not what I was
into so I wanted to say positively like
better than a lot of the clickfunnels
products seems which is kind of
horrifying but anyway I'm gonna wrap
this video up Oh drink more guys breathe
more it's all life waters life airs life
Coffee zillah's life maybe I don't know
studies show that people who have the
free time to watch coffee still are six
significantly more grateful so grateful
this is life which is you know is air
which is music which is water which is
I don't know let's just put some be
enemies by this bad boy ed let's just
keep going okay its water its life its
air its breath it's the truth you know
what I mean it's the truth and it's
Prince E and it's my school too
so if I just keep talking to you guys
with that little nice piano track maybe
maybe you believe it too dr. geiszler